[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream Q&A section for
livestream 15 I am here with dr. Heather
hang we have questions overflowing our
browsers and we are going to do our best
to address as many of them as possible
we're going to start with two questions
from Twitter which I promised to do the
first question by the way how does
printing suck so badly it's 20/20 why
can the printer not figure out what I
wanted to do it's a mystery
alright first what if we want the
printer to have that much access to your
brain I just wanted to behave and I want
it not to behave badly when it knows I'm
on deadline why does it always screw up
yeah all right Benjamin asks begins with
Thanks could you both give a simple
tutorial for lay people on how to
distinguish between valid evolutionary
theories and explanations and
over-fitting just so stories especially
in evopsych much love from spain this is
a great question it deserves a 15 or 20
minute tutorial at some point but let's
just say for the moment that the the
basics are the same as for any other
hypothesis driven science the one
difference is biology is complex and
therefore sometimes the standards have
to be different it's very easy to
falsify a true biological idea with two
highest standard in other words to
accept some sort of noise as a
falsification but other than that
hypotheses lead to predictions and those
predictions are what tells you whether
or not this is valid and so what I would
say is when hypotheses are offered ask
what the predictions are now it may take
some time this there's kind of an art to
generating predictions it's not simple
one gets better at it with practice but
the hypothesis and the predictions are a
package and to the extent that the
predictions are either pretty pretty
certain to be true they're not very high
quality to the extent that they're
surprising counterintuitive and
definitely outside the range of what the
person offering the hypothesis would
have reason to know then they are high
quality and so anyway I would just say
hypothetically code adducted method is
philosophically well understood it's not
different in biology and the question is
do you know how it works and can you
apply it and it will prevent you from
overfitting in fact it will correct when
you have engaged in overfitting it will
tell you what you don't want to know
because it's it's that good a method so
this definitely warrants several
separate conversations and this isn't
exactly an answer to the question of a
simple tutorial for how to distinguish
but I will say that I used to begin
every single one of my programs at
Evergreen with an exercise that I had
modified from one that the organization
for tropical studies did with students
when they were learning how to be
tropical biologists in Costa Rica and
Panama and involved taking all of my
students out somewhere out of sight of
everyone else and just dropping them
there for two hours with a pen and a
notebook and hopefully nothing else and
saying be still use your senses watch
your brain tell you it's Borden that
it's screaming and you need to leave and
once that slows down start observing
those things that are happening outside
of your brain and write down the
questions that occur to you that's the
first half and then in the second half
everyone comes back together better if
it's the next day so now I'm just in the
afternoon of the same day and in small
groups looks at everyone's questions
everyone writes down maybe their two
favorite questions and the two favorite
questions of the person sitting next to
them and then as a group they try to
figure out the hypotheses that might
address the questions and the
predictions that follow from they saw
those hypotheses
then in an all group melee and all group
and all class free-for-all we all
discuss a few of these hypotheses that
were generated from each of the small
groups and it is amazing to see not just
what kinds of observations people make
but what kinds of hypotheses they
generated for those observations and
what predictions would inherently follow
from this hypotheses but also how
dedicated people can't become two
hypotheses that they have generated less
than 24 hours before and now are willing
to fiercely defend it seems with almost
with their lives and so it is a lesson
not only in how to do science
specifically field science in this case
but science in general but also in how
quickly human psychology can twist
itself around to defend things that it
didn't even know existed mere moments an
evolutionary timescale before yeah it's
an important topic and separating a
hypothesis that is valid from a
hypothesis that I myself am advocating
for is important the advocacy has no
philosophical implication and should
have no impact on what you think about
the truth or or not of a given given
question all right second question from
Twitter is for both of us from echo hmm
let's see Brett how do you disagree with
Jordan Peterson on the function of the
transcendent you say the idea of God is
a software hack Peterson says I act as
if God exists God is a conceptualization
of one's future self with whom one can
bargain I say that is i Brett say I
can't it can be done through metaphor
and must be done through it cannot now
be done through metaphor must now be
done through insight and enlightenment
what is the nuance don't you think we're
more wired for metaphor etc yes first of
all I would say we are damned if we do
and damned if we don't
and I would advise people actually take
a look at rational rules recently did a
analysis of Harris and Peterson on stage
with me moderate
and engaged this question very directly
and I would say the difference between
what Peterson and I believe is this and
I mean this came out on stage and
rationality rule is highlighted it is
that because these metaphors that
function in lieu of the literal truths
are responsive to environments which we
may no longer live in we cannot rely on
them to the extent that we are faced
with novel problems and so that is the
problem with going with the evolutionary
solution rather than the insight and
analytics based solution but the insight
and analytics based solution is error
prone in the present because it takes a
while for the truth to settle down into
something that is actually robust that
is to say there's a lot of false starts
in science where you think you
understand something and you don't quite
and it bounces back and forth until it
settles and so neither of these is great
but I would argue the level of novelty
in the current environment is so great
we really don't have a choice we know
that yes some of those metaphorical
truths
retain their currency a few might even
be timeless but in general they won't be
I would say just to add a tiny bit more
to this the objection that you had
onstage with Jordan is exactly as you
say and is even less robust than the
objection that you and I both have to
Pinker's suggestion that basically we
live in a Pangloss Ian's world it's the
best of all possible worlds and given
this trajectory it's only it's only
getting better this suggests in order
for that to be true the future must look
like the past and this is also true for
the time-honored truths that are in
things like religious texts that in
order for all of those to be the way
that we need to continue to act the
future must continue to look like the
past and of course the rate of change is
such that we see very little evidence to
suggest that the future will at least in
every regard continue to look like the
past future already doesn't and it's
going to look ever less so all right
hopefully those were satisfying answers
all right on to the super chat yeah so
at 2:10 here we're starting so we're
gonna spend about half an hour on the
super chat questions from the first
round and then we'll switch to any that
come in on the second okay there was a
post on reddit our science by dr. James
Dewar kovat 19 did not come to the room
on Institute of virology a discussion
about theories of origin from your
friendly neighborhood virologist I would
like a thoughts on it I love your show I
don't know of this it came in at the top
level of super check questions so it's
at the top of our list the top monetary
level so I took a very brief look at it
during the break it has a long piece and
I must say I am actually encouraged by
the fact that it's a long piece you will
remember we are advocating we are hoping
that this turns out to be a natural
virus and it would be wonderful if that
evidence showed up in this post however
i Doan to it almost at random in order
to figure out how credible this was and
the place I landed was a section in the
middle of the thing that said if this
was an engineered virus that that would
have left hallmarks in the genome which
that is a not true one of the things we
know is that it in at least one
published paper the Ralph Barrack lab
prides itself on having done a seamless
job of genetic engineering so we know a
this is possible and B that this is
considered desirable and an
accomplishment in laboratory
environments when it happens the other
thing is that this particular virus does
appear to have some of that evidence I
believe in association with the furan
site there is a a bit of a restriction
fragment this is a location that is cut
by particular enzymes that look for
particular genetic sequences and there's
a long history of using these things if
you can cut DNA or RNA at a particular
sequence point and then do something
like run it out on a gel so that the
different length molecules move
different distances and then you can cut
the piece out of the gel you have a set
of molecules that has effectively been
filtered by length when it is restricted
at these sites and so
you would tend to find in some cases
those sequences would be in the piece
that you then having separated out
through this filtration mechanism
imported back into a genome now is the
site long enough that it couldn't have
come about by random chance I don't know
but to say that there isn't any evidence
of it is wrong there's some evidence how
strong the evidence is we could debate
but anyway that is maybe it's the only
error in this guy's analysis but I do
think it's an error and it was where I
landed when I plunged into this document
at random so my guess is the where we
will come out is the thing that I
believe we can say with certainty is
that you cannot be certain of the origin
of this virus nobody who is telling you
that it couldn't have come from a lab is
telling you the truth
because that cannot be certain based on
what we currently see I think that is
the case if it is not the case I would
be pleased to discover it and it will be
personally embarrassing for me to have
to admit it but I will be pleased
because it means we're far better off
going forward and I would like us to be
far better off and I would say
embarrassing
maybe but really you've been so careful
as both of us aim to be all the time
about saying this is a hypothesis for
which I see more and more evidence and
you know in this particular case you
really hope it's not true but that that
does not change the the analysis
ultimately which is to say if it turns
out that all the evidence that you're
seeing and that we're seeing right now
turn out to be erroneous or overwhelmed
by contravening evidence fabulous and
come you know we'll come and say that
and I guess I'm not even sure that it
warrants embarrassment it's it's
unfortunate it'd be better would you
know it would be an easier life if you
were always right if we were if we were
all always right and of course that's
not going to happen yeah I mean I think
this this is worth spending a moment on
it is embarrassing whether it should be
or shouldn't be it is embarrassing
however it's a lot like quitting smoking
right quitting
is famously difficult but it gets more
difficult the longer you've been smoking
so the fact that it's difficult is not
an argument against it
in this case being wrong when you have
taken a position and you know been
mocked for it
discovering that actually there's
something wrong with your position is
not a pleasant experience but
discovering that earlier is far better
than continuing to double down on the
wrong idea and so comparatively speaking
it's a relief to get to the other side
of that thing and I will face the
embarrassment if that's what it comes to
but so far that has not been the
direction good okay for three Geographic
next question for three geographic
locations a B and C B is closer to a C
is far away from me so it's linearly a
next to be next to see would you expect
bat Cove B that is to say from location
B to be closer genetically to bat Cove a
than Back Cove C to back of a assume
similar bats so I'm gonna just reframe
that in I think I understand what the
question is and it's well written it's
just hard probably to interpret for
people who are merely hearing it rather
than reading it if you've got three
locations arrayed in a line in which a
and C are farthest apart from one
another and B is intermediate would we
expect I you know all else being equal
is is unstated here that a virus
emerging from B is more closely related
to that emerging from a then the one
from C is to a that is to say if if
nothing else is different between these
these species and the environments and
everything else is physical proximity
decent proxy for relatedness and yeah
but the all else being equal question is
is the big one
the all else being equal question is the
big one and I hate it when people follow
and all else being equal with the claim
that all else is never equal because
that's not the point of its inclusion
here but in this case it is especially
unlikely that they are equal so for one
thing let's just point to the fact that
you've got locations a B and C in a
world of airplanes right airplanes
invalidate the
here as long as those locations are far
enough that people you know can
transport this virus and it could
potentially move back and forth I mean I
guess not I guess I guess if you're
talking for your bats but here's the
other thing so I worked on fruit bats
there was a species of fruit bat on the
island Barrow Colorado where I was
working
you're a derma baile bottom and I had an
argument with my advisor my bat advisor
on the island about whether this animal
ever roost it on the island I turned out
to be right it did but the reason that
he one of the world's leading experts on
fruit bats did not believe it too was
that it did not live there year-round
it's circulated from one island to the
next and there was a particular season
in which this animal would fly on to the
island and roost because I was studying
its roosting ecology I detected that it
was present and there he was netting
bats and so he never knew if they were
flying onto the island and then going
home or or what but my point is the
physical location of Yura derma was
actually in motion based on the presence
or absence of ripe fruit on the island
and so the physical location if you had
islands in proximity the fact that some
creature had flown from one island to
another and started roosting there would
not predict to which other population
its viruses would be most closely
related so anyway forget my airplane
analogy obviously with people that works
with bats it doesn't but in the case of
bats there is an awful lot in the
ecology that would tend to make the
connection between populations of
viruses inhabiting bats very very noisy
but as Heather said all else being equal
in general there will be a closer
connection between those populations in
close proximity yeah I mean flight
flight changes everything right so in
general the bio geographic distribution
of organisms is very different for birds
and for bats and for other flying
organisms especially that can fly across
any large body of water then it's going
to be for something that had to either
draught somewhere or wait for the
continents to shift either you know
through getting someplace to dispersal
of vicariance okay glad to see you two
looking healthy well thank you
for a next project I would like to
recommend you produce a nature
documentary or documentary series on
that strangest of all creatures and
second most intelligent on earth humans
I want to know which most until I
I did too I want to know what you think
this the most intelligent species is
well thank you for that ok recently had
a discussion on an article quote
findings suggest that a pandemic may
promote preference for traditional
gender roles interested in your thoughts
parentheses I doubt the articles quality
okay so I'm gonna highlight this or Zack
if you could highlight this so go back
to it and maybe address it next time
six seven is hailed professors do y'all
like turtles
you know I am nominally a herpetologist
which means that the organisms that I
kind of at one point knew the most about
where the so called herps which is a
terrible group it's not actually a valid
version of grouping but it includes
amphibians and reptiles but not birds so
you know that's a conversation for you
know three of you another time the three
of you who care about that but turtles
are obviously included in that and I'd
find Turtles the least interesting of
the lot and I'm not sure why but they
and they don't agonize me I just I'm
just not really into him um all right
salamanders more interesting Sicilians
legless tropical amphibians and her
interest to hate people from Sicily and
also people from Sicily who have links
yes I would point out that we have to
get through this question successfully
in order to get to dinner which makes
this a test to dine oh dear oh that was
a terrible pun terrible and yeah and
still most people have no idea what
you're talking about
oh thank goodness alright yes I kind of
like never to explain it
no I think I'm not now they have Google
most of them so yeah yes I like turtles
I interesting thing about turtles
turtles in the Amazon very frequently
have
butterflies if the turtles pull out of
the water they haul out onto a log and
they sit there in the Sun and
butterflies land on their on their heads
and I think collect salt from tears and
things any way you can if you google it
you'll find dozens of photos of this but
here's the tragic thing we were just in
the Amazon and we saw in January far
fewer butterflies we saw internalist
Earth of insects but for the turtles we
saw and given that there were less
Turtles you might expect that they would
be more set upon by the butterflies but
there appeared to be far fewer
butterflies and this was in a very
remote location so you know we were
talking about the possibility of
pesticides working their way downstream
and the water shed or something but
anyway insectivorous birds are also
beginning to disappear they are they are
yeah so that that again is a
conversation for their time let me just
say one one upbeat thing about turtles
which most people don't know which is
that their their carapace and plaster on
the shell the top and the bottom of the
shell are actually so rigid that they
don't do a very good job of breathing
within that so they actually have
accessory lungs in their legs that is
true cool I can't use the said of those
it probably would yeah please consider
sharing your views on Joe Rogan's
podcast you can also have an argument
lockdown or not with him greetings from
a Czech Republic and thank you for all
the content we'd love to UM we don't
live in LA but I would be willing to
travel for that for sure you say viruses
evolved to be less deadly since it
spreads well among the young and healthy
with little deadliness am i right to
think that it becomes less deadly at
half the rate as it would if it had
uniform deadliness approximately half
the rate he says I'm not sure even with
that approximately in front of the half
I'm not sure where that where this comes
from quite
Wow I'm sure I'm sure I'm just missing a
logical step here but I don't I can't
imagine what it would be yeah both of us
feel free to rephrase that question and
send it to us one way or the other yeah
sorry about that you said a few podcasts
ago that herpes and coronavirus might
interact to cause internal damage can
you elaborate on this are you talking
about HS F 1 or 2 or both and what do we
know about the damage love the podcast
I'm not sure we can distinguish between
the two both of those are that's herpes
simplex virus 1 & 2 so rather not herpes
complex we're talking about simplex only
I think the way it interacts is this
virus seems to cross into the central
nervous system and these herpes viruses
reside in neurons that's where they are
latent and something about the the
cytokine storm the Cascade the
inflammation cascade that unfolds causes
pressure on something that causes people
to lose their sense of smell and taste
maybe that's one thing they lose their
sense of smell which degrades their
sense of taste which would be normal so
anyway that's what I think we know I
don't think that that conclusion has
changed very much
in the weeks since we talked about it
but I haven't run into anything new on
it but yeah you know the rate of the
rate of new information is growing about
as quickly as the rate of infections is
growing in some places it's it's really
hard to keep track of everything which
actually raises one thing I just want to
put a flag here for next time one of the
consequences of a highly exploitative
virus is that it may be uh pending many
of the assumptions that we utilize in
other words what does this virus do may
not be a good question if the virus is
more variable than we think it is do you
test it you know what is the rate of
false positives and or false negatives
of these tests that may not be a good
question because it could be that a
virus from over here on a test
from over there causes a high rate of
failures etc and so anyway this is an
yet another reason that we need to know
what critter we're dealing with and does
it have an unusual tendency to change
that affects the likelihood of a vaccine
functioning it affects the likelihood
that a vaccine would give permanent
immunity it affects all kinds of things
yeah so this this is something we should
definitely return to this is something
we intended to talk about when we're
talking about the exploratory nature of
a lab selected virus and the idea we're
seeing so many tests of you know broadly
three types but out of so many different
places with highly variable rates of
false negative some false positives and
one of the one of the reasons for the
hypothesis for why these tests are so
not just imprecise and largely
inaccurate but actually variably
inaccurate would be that the virus is
mutating so quickly is evolving so
quickly that a test generated in an area
with a particular strain of the virus
may work to find that virus that version
of the virus but not other strains that
are circulating elsewhere
so if true one thing that would suggest
would be that the tests should be
basically used in the area in which they
are first generated and or include
multiple strains the you know the
antibodies from multiple strains not
just from one yeah you know obviously if
the thing is if it's happening at the
level of mutation this will leave a
hallmark that is visible and people are
doing sequencing I guess I have a
question and maybe it's just simply
knowable about whether these are whole
genome this is a very large gene oh yeah
for a virus it's like it maxes out viral
genomes yeah 30 kilobytes or something
Tom yeah but the question is are people
sequencing the whole thing if they're
not you can do a phylogeny by sequencing
little bits the more of it you sequence
the better the data you get and the more
accurate your phylogeny will be in the
less noisy it will be but I don't know
what they're using in order to figure
out how many strains are out there and
if it's scatter shot it may be that
we're missing it maybe experimenting in
certain regions of its genome and not
others if these are whole genome
sequences which are now readily possible
then that's much less likely okay dan
says I've been a long I've long been a
fan of rum and my current favorite is
roans a cop busts into the audio
anything trace what is your current
favorite rum I don't know you know the
more the older Florida Canas they're
very I was just gonna say the older
Florida Konya and Abuelo's mutt
not not bad either well it's okay there
are some very fancy ones I should say we
tend to have field biologist instincts
in this in this which is to say you get
any dark rum you can come by when you're
in the field yeah you know Florida Konya
is made in Nicaragua it's been available
in Costa Rica and Panama where we've
worked but in part our affinity for rum
has a lot to do with the fact that a
allergy to wheat takes a huge number of
things off the menu and so I don't think
that's explanatory we were long before
you discovered an allergy to wheat we
were drinking rum because rum is what's
available in Latin America in places
where there are field stations that
aren't dry yep and it is reliable that
drinking rum drives away snobs because
they all look down on it for some reason
so this is just a comment Tim Poole
doesn't engage much with Twitter he
probably doesn't know you think he took
your tweet too far next time I catch a
live stream I'll send him with super
chat referencing this video appreciate
it
do we expect to be able to create a
vaccine given its of the RNA virus if
not do we have a clear path for
quarantine decisions regarding the u.s.
that we simply modify a reaction to Cove
it to our capacity to care for our sick
you know I think this is a lot of
questions and we've we've addressed each
of them a bit in other places one of
them being there are plenty of vaccines
for RNA virus
is including was like yellow fever and
various flu viruses and I can t remember
there was a long list that we went into
last time I don't think yellow fever but
the flu for sure but we know the fever
was on there the flu obviously tells us
that vaccine vaccine is not a vaccine
because the flu vaccine is famously
ineffective in many years and when it's
effective that effectiveness doesn't
last and so anyway do note that vaccine
doesn't mean we come up with this thing
and suddenly the problem is over it
would be lovely if it meant that a
vaccine is probably years out and if it
does occur it might not be a complete
solution is that can you click on don't
put this thing on it could you click on
14 I don't have back my trackpad isn't
working
thank you yes please let's let me just
here I'll ask the next question while
you answering and I'll find this do part
two of previous question share our
freedoms be limited by our care capacity
if we have capacity to care for more
patients is it moral to make Americans
suffer financially when hospital beds
are open thank you you two are great I'm
probably missing the meaning of that
question I think we have a general
problem which is that our collective
well-being and our individual well-being
are in many cases at odds and we at some
level cannot afford to navigate that by
intuition or by everyone being free to
opt in or opt out as they would because
that will create a game theoretic hazard
for those people who feel the most
obligation and it will create advantages
for those who feel the least obligation
to their fellow man so at some level we
have to do something that deals with the
distinction between the individual level
and the population level that said I
think one of the things that is driving
Heather and me crazy is that it appears
that there
many parts of the system that wish to
resolve this puzzle by lying by
pretending that the population level
well-being and the individual level
well-being are the same and that anybody
who questions anything about the story
they are telling is somehow not getting
the the scientific reality of it and
this is just not the case it's time for
us to grow up and talk about free-rider
problems and vaccines and things like
that and to do it honorably and
completely rather than by wagging our
fingers at people and telling them that
they're imagining things this is in fact
in some ways the central tension that
tends to describe the distinction
between people on the left and people on
the right is are you more focused on
individual level freedoms versus
population level well-being and the
increasingly the scientific when we are
told that the scientific consensus says
X it is often about promoting population
level well-being which is honorable and
important and in a globalised world is
what we need
but by then shaming people into
imagining that there is no distinction
between population level and individual
level analyses you get a lot of people
more likely to be on the right but
plenty of people on the left - saying
what the hell I know that there's a
difference between intellect individual
and population level health and
well-being
and if you're claiming that actually
there is no distinction I don't trust
anything you say so it is brought it is
also like you know it's not that
lockdowns are bad it's that stupid
lockdowns are bad right that the way
it's being done is is wrong and we need
to be able to pick and choose the
aspects of it as we critique it and say
actually the Loctite needs to be done
smart so that people don't start
disobeying one rule that's stupid and
then decide that they're going to
disobey the whole thing it is also the
case that at the point we allow the
authoritative sources to tell fibs in
the interest of our collective
well-being that they begin to tell fibs
in their own interest
that are actually at odds with the
public's well-being and once the public
discovers that it destroys the
credibility that those authoritative
sources need to have so the whole thing
is so corrosive of good policy that it
has to go we've got to do this
explicitly completely in the open that's
the way it has to happen that's right so
just to pick up on what do we have
vaccines what RNA viruses do we have
vaccines for as we talked about last
time the science news article critiquing
the plan demmick video says claims that
we have vaccines for these RNA viruses
influenza measles mumps rubella rabies
yellow fever and Ebola that's quite a
lot
where were we we're gonna try to get
through a few more of these you have
spoken to likelihood that the virus
originated in the lab do you think
they're covering that up or do you think
it got out and even they don't know how
seem significant does seem significant
that's a very good question good
question
let's let's sort this carefully based on
what I've seen so far I'm speaking only
for me I believe it is more likely to
have come from the lab than not that
could change I'd be happy to see it
change if it came from the lab I believe
the lab that it came from has a very
high degree of certainty that it did
come from the lab it would be very
difficult if this had been something
well I should say if it is modified by a
lab they would have a very high degree
of certainty that it had come from their
lab if it was one of many samples and it
escaped before it got cataloged or
something like that it's possible it's
possible that they wouldn't but I would
think that if it came from the lab the
lab in question knows it and the lab in
question might have the instinct to
discuss it openly and honorably if the
if this is one of the labs in wuhan they
may not be free to and so one of the
things that I would have our audience
think carefully about is if it is in the
interest of the world to understand the
origin of this and the origin of this is
anything but natural then how do we find
the generosity of spirit to
free those people who know the most
about what this is to tell us what they
know that's the question right this is
not about vengeance or blame if this is
from the lab the chances are this is the
result of an error in judgment of the
scientific community this was discussed
I believe in 2015 there was a question
about gain-of-function research in
coronaviruses discussed in our top
journals about whether or not this was
safe or might result in some very
serious epidemic
so is this that maybe but if it is in
2015 we had a chance to stop this kind
of research we didn't this happened in
some sense that's the scientific
community's responsibility now let's
deal with this question completely
without prepared pretending that it's
settled okay next question
Bret you're an evolutionary theorist
please check out the generational
hormone hypothesis it explains why the
corona virus will hit the Western
populations much worse than other
nations and a second part of the same
question the generational hormonal
hypothesis described how Western human
populations are in a generational
hormone cycle since the ACTH levels are
increasing I don't know anything about
this do you I know nothing about it I
would say I'm unclear so a hormone is
basically a signal molecule that
operates at a distance across the body
it doesn't operate between individuals
you could have a pheromone or something
that would so anyway I think they're
referencing some change in hormone
levels between generations but again we
have such a novel environment especially
at the level of hormones with all of the
estrogens that we're putting into the
world in the plastics that we make and
the pesticides that we use we are doing
all sorts of things that have nothing to
do with some evolutionary pattern but
will affect human physiology and the
hormones given to livestock hormones
given to livestock yeah the list is
endless of the number of ways that we're
interfering with the endocrine system so
I'd be interested if there was a good
evolutionary hypothesis but that is not
the only source of a pattern
yeah yeah have either of you followed
Chris Martenson with peak prosperity
I seems to be very much the same page as
you guys also FYI wired magnet studies
have not followed the smartest Martinson
okay I'd be curious about the studies
yep
next question have you read the book
rare-earth if so what is your opinion of
the hypothesis of the emergence of
complex life is a none probable
improbable combination of special
Astrophysical geological events and
conditions have not read the book I'm
not familiar with it the emergence of
complex life is improbable and yet it
happened yes and I mean I'm not clear
what's loaded into the tournament
probable here so improbable as to be
doubtful no and I've engaged a lot of
those hypotheses and my sense is they're
actually onto something I think there is
a mechanism that is not understood
evolutionarily that fills in some of the
what amounts to gobbledygook in the
story that our evolution textbooks tell
but it's very Darwinian the thing that
fits in that space is Darwinian it's not
sir a challenge to Darwin but I don't
know frankly I don't know we'd have to
look at the at this book and I haven't
read it yeah I'm not sure if you've
touched on it yet but have you do you
have any thoughts in the recent Joe
Rogan episode with Elon Musk eelain's
opinion seems to be that the world
should go back to normal thanks not seen
that episode I'm not sure I could handle
it given how Elan musk seems to be
handling reality at least through social
media these days but yeah he does seem
to be very much in the we need to go
back to normal camp and and as far as
what I've seen of his positioning he
seems aggressive without being based in
the reality that I'm seeing anywhere
yeah
Erik is an interesting poll about in the
light of Elan seeming to go off the
rails do people want him sent to the
cornfield or did they want more of him I
mean Erik didn't use that phrase but in
any case in the poll you know it's a
Twitter poll it's not scientific but the
poll came back with
people wanting more elan in spite of his
apparent harebrained ness at the moment
and I must say I'm in the same camp I
think you know he has a clear conflict
of interest here whether it's affecting
his opinion I don't know but I don't I
don't love the way he's behaving but he
has been very generative I'm concerned
that a guy who's gotten to where he's
gotten has done so by gambling sometimes
when an individual should be free to do
it but you don't do it on behalf of
civilization and so it may be that he
has gambling in his blood and he's now
ready to gamble on all our behalf and
it's not his to do but I mean it seems
like there's two different questions and
I think you did a little a little
switching here and you switched the
other question you said I want more Elan
and that's that's fine that's you know
that's an anti censorship censorship
position as opposed to what do you think
of what he's saying
so I mean I think we've been very
careful about threading this needle
around I want I want all of the opinions
that want to be voiced to be voice able
and findable by those who look at the
same time as being able to critique them
and so you're just beginning to get into
why why does it seem like he's got he's
now holding opinions that seem
potentially dangerous at a public health
level that is worth investigating
while not being in any way suggestive
that you think you should therefore
either choose to sit down and shut up or
should be forced to sit down and shut up
well I I think I want to put this into
an idiom that you and I have discussed
before so we have talked about the
difference between and the tension
between culture and consciousness and
that maps onto a bunch of other things
including a distinction between the
shamanistic and the sacred mm-hm and I
think the problem is that Elon okay but
you just switch those let's just keep it
in the same order culture is to
consciousness as the sacred is the
shamanistic perfect yeah I think the
problem is that because Elon comes
across on a high-tech high competence
channel that that's his ethos
that we tend to read him as more in the
sacred cultural mode and in some sense
he may be more shamanistic and the thing
about the shaman is you don't want the
shaman in charge of policy that's not
the shamans role but the shaman
adventures on to the possible frontier
and they may come back with visions but
the point is in order for shamanism to
work you have to not be obligated to
their advice expect most of the visions
to be nuts
and some of the visions to sound nuts
and not be right and there's no question
that elan has some visions that are not
nuts and then he's got a bunch of others
that I find preposterous so maybe maybe
what you're saying is not only should he
obviously not be censored but that you
actually you personally are interested
in continuing to have sort of the
ticker-tape of elon continuing to run in
the back of your mind because there will
be he's in such a mode right now that
it's become easy to dismiss him and a
lot of people are saying I just don't
want to hear him anymore
and you're saying I actually want to
continue to hear the stuff that's coming
out of that guy's brain because in the
past he's understood some things that
the rest of us haven't and he may be
about to come to something like that
here yes and in fact I want to hear him
even when he's crazy
right I'm not looking to filter it but I
want to personally be able to filter it
I want to be able to take any Elan idea
and say don't know what that is I'm
gonna put it aside but I you know I want
to hear him during the pandemic I don't
want to follow his advice because I
think it's wrong so good anyway I want
him in the room yeah okay so I think
we're gonna just switch to the next
super chat questions and we'll come back
to these if if we have time which I hope
we do because there are a lot of good
ones and I apologize that we got through
relatively few Sara line okay here we go
are there any organizations that solve
societal problems like tissue
regenerators as they grow more numerous
and effective we grow stronger in the
short run but
of them become cancerous and dangerous
that's the questions are really pushing
the bounds this time yeah are there can
you read that again are ya put my
glasses on are there organizations that
solve societal problems like tissue
regenerators as they grow more numerous
and effective we grow stronger in the
short run but more of them become
cancerous and dangerous okay so I think
- I think we're both hung up on the
tissue - generators yeah frizz I don't i
already trying to do there any
organizations trying to do this i want
to zoom back out on the question I don't
think organizations is what we want to
focus okay there are many processes that
in their success actually make us
fragile right and we are seeing this
actually across the board where the
relative ease in which we live has
caused us to become soft and I believe
we are actually we have become incapable
of doing some of the things that are
necessary and if you look back at
history we just saw at Zacks
recommendation we just saw the movie
1917 which is absolutely excellent but
it reminds it reminds us of what in this
case men had to do right and the fact is
it's it's astonishing and to the extent
that it took tens of millions of Russian
lives to turn direct the German war
machine around they had to do it now
they had an authoritarian state ready to
tell them that they had to do it but the
point is it was also in the Russian
character and we have lived with such
ease that now we have an epidemic of
snowflake eree
that is the opposite of having what it
takes to you know to douse the the core
of a nuclear reactor that's melted down
or to you know turn around
a vile enemy as it advances over your
land or any one of these things and so
yes I think many things that succeed
actually sow the seeds of our undoing
and we have to we should engineer a
civilization with this in mind so that
we produce antifragility fertility
rather than fertility I would say also
to your point about war at the same time
that the four of us watch 1917 and we
actually watched we watched good morning
Vietnam after you began the last
livestream with that and I've also been
reading Sebastian youngers book war
about which he then was Sebastian Junger
was then I don't remember producer
director on the documentary Restrepo it
is an extraordinary look into modern
warfare but at the effectively the
infantry level and I'm sure I'm using
the wrong word here but he posits that
in part being engaged in actual combat
is a is alluring to those who have
engaged in it and it's pretty much all
men certainly was all men until recently
in history and isn't generally all men
because not not because it makes you
feel alive there's lots of things that
can make you feel alive I think his
example is skydiving makes you feel
alive but it makes you feel maximally
utilized the idea that at the moment of
combat of being in combat that you know
that you would lay your life down for
another human being and that they would
lay their life down for you and that you
are actually an important a key piece in
the puzzle of keeping your fellow man
alive is absolutely exhilarating and how
in fact do you go back effectively to a
society that tries to sell you coke and
Cheetos and encourages you to work some
crap job after you have actually been
utilized so fully at such a young age
yeah and there's a question about what
this has to do with the PTSD that people
come back with absolutely that you know
they they get it when they come back
in general and at some level it's it's
hard to confront a mundane generic world
mm-hmm
even when the alternative is horrifying
yeah that's right what's more important
allow open discussion or prevent harmful
advice who may be bad but it's nothing
better most people on YouTube are not
experts why endanger them what do we get
love from Russia so what's more
important to allow open discussion or
prevent harmful advice allow open
discussion and it's not that that answer
won't end up harming some people as well
but well I would just add as soon as you
decide to stop to start protecting
people from discussion of alternative
possibilities you a blind us we can't go
forward if you don't have people willing
to navigate the murkiness at the fringe
of what is understood and be worse you
get corruption the corrupters will take
your apparatus that you build to protect
people from bad advice and they will use
it to enrich themselves and to hobble
the rest of us and [ __ ] them I'm
absolutely sick of the idea that we
needed to be - we need to be protected
from discussion of anything frankly we
should be able to handle the discussion
even the gross stuff even the awful
stuff even the dangerous stuff let's
talk about it like adults and people
will respond well it's the fact that
people have the sense that there's
something you're not telling them and
that it's reinforced by the fact that
indeed there are things you're not
telling them that makes this problem
really poisonous yeah so the next
several refer to people that we people
in work that we are not familiar with so
I'm not sure it's worth I don't know
Paul Bingham on the human uniqueness
problem or Jacob Linville on Sorento
both announcing the identification of
lab made antibodies with high potency
against the virus that sounds
interesting but I don't know I don't
know anything about it back to the ABC
question yes LS being equal so I'm not
trying to skip questions but some of
these
I'm just not sure what we can do with
them so let's go here Bret population
cycles this is actually another follow
up population cycles and an increased
ACTH levels and the animals die from
disease my generational hormone
hypothesis says that Western human
populations are in this phase especially
the u.s. is that possible
I wouldn't put so much on ACTH and
particular which I god I can't remember
what the acronym it's a hormone age
stands for home and I can't remember
what the AC T stands for at the moment I
would say with high confidence that
hormonal disruption disruption of
hormonal systems in humans and across
vertebrates that have the same kinds of
hormones that we have is highly
explanatory and much of the disease both
individuals and ecosystem level and
that's happening across the world but I
would be very surprised if a major
source of human illness and injury was
traced to a particular hormone disruptor
like this well yeah I'm still not clear
on whether this is an evolutionary
hypothesis being offered in which case I
think you have to ask yourself the
question hormones are messengers from
one part of the body to one or more
other parts of the body to the extent
that the message is causing a disruptive
pattern there's a question about why the
message is being sent or interpreted the
way it is it doesn't make sense for
evolution to set you up for failure and
focusing on the message rather than the
pattern is going to be a mistake so if
if the suggestion is that there's a
natural evolutionary pattern I want to
understand why evolution would have
built it then then maybe there's
something to talk about any reason as to
why countries in the Indian subcontinent
have relatively lower death rates due to
covin we talked about this in one of the
previous live streams I'm sorry I can't
point you to exactly where right now
yeah I remember let's say it's an
interesting question and one of the
things that we
are likely to do in the upcoming live
streams let's talk a little bit about
some data on the distinctions between
countries but I think as far as we know
India is still a bit anomalous I
actually don't know where they stand at
the moment but certainly as of a couple
weeks ago which is when we were talking
about it that was true we have we seen
Peak prosperity YouTube channel it has
been covering kovat since January really
accurate forecasting a lot of the events
developed I have not I think I
encountered it for the first time today
okay um so anyway I had a few minutes
and there were some things on it I found
disturbing and then there were some
things that seemed interesting but
anyway it will take a deeper dive yep
can you talk about the relationship
between unique ability and talent and
disability trauma in humans yeah
especially now where human civilization
tends to point people in the direction
of basically trading your time and
talents doing other people's bidding in
exchange for money that you then spend
on frivolous entertainment or whatever
that's not a recipe for insight to the
extent that you face some sort of hazard
that disrupts normal development that's
not a good thing but it opens the door
to the patterns that will track you into
useless kagura
and might divert you into something
useful so in some sense I would say that
those people who have been disrupted in
their development have suffered a
setback but it's one that opens the
possibility of ending up somewhere
distinct and unique each each you know
there's a the Anna Karenina principle
you know each happy family is alike each
unhappy family is unhappy in its own
unique way every functional airplane is
alike every disrupted airplane is its
own unique flying machine there's a way
in which disruption alters things and
makes them unique
and the result is often failure and
catastrophe but it also opens the door
to discovery so human development is
sort of the ghost that haunts so many
discussions about about human capacity
yeah now we talked about this fair bit
in the childhood chapter of our book as
well and and in an otherwise not I think
very interesting video I talked about
this and one of the big think videos but
let me just say that with regard to the
question is what what is the
relationship between unique ability
talent and disability and trauma and it
says this is gonna seem semantic but
both of us have argued with the framing
of many of the things that are called
disability as in fact disability and so
specifically a lot of the things that
are now being sort of categorized under
narrow diversity seem to because they
put a young child out of step with
standard sit down face forward shut up
raise your hand when you have a question
need to use the bathroom model of
schooling if you have anything that's a
bit different about you that keeps you
from not playing that game perfectly you
are more likely to then to start seeing
other problems with the system and maybe
then maybe be forced to in fact develop
particular talents and so some of these
so-called disabilities which you know we
have argued both of us separately and
together before are not likely to be
disabilities are things like dyslexia or
ADHD or color blindness even or left
handedness and and and the list goes on
and on and on Oh autism spectrum you
know Asperger's you know the shallow end
of the autism spectrum so a lot of these
things just allow for you to stand in a
slightly different place force you to
stand in a slightly different place as
you try to access the standard model of
resources that society wants to hand to
you and it kind of allows scales to fall
from the eyes and people to start people
in such positions to become incapable of
seeing the standard-issue school and
employment opportunities and everything
else about society that so many people
are otherwise just kind of slotting into
yeah and it also
cross-culturally at what shamans are
there are basically a lot of ways to
disrupt normal thought and thought does
not collapse when normal thought is
disrupted something else takes its place
and it is error-prone but insite prone
at the same time and so anyway human
populations deal with this and you can
you can get there a lot of ways but
let's put it this way misfits have been
a fascination for us for a long time and
we saw a lot of what they're capable of
in the classroom and society is so
foolish to throw away their capacity
because they're not easy to educate in
an economically efficient fashion good I
remember on Joe Rogan I remember on
Jerry Joe Rogan said to you the Catholic
Church is a cult and you said back it's
not a cult can you elaborate yeah run
afoul of Jill Rogan and Sam Harris once
here but the Catholic Church is I guess
the church is not a couple thousand
years old but Catholicism is an
outgrowth of an innovation that goes
back a couple thousand years I would
argue it's an update of an earlier
innovation you've got the Moses version
then you got the jesus version in the
Catholic Church is a a manifestation of
the Christian update to this compendium
of ancient wisdom is the Catholic Church
does it have a corruption problem yes it
obviously has a pedophilia problem on
the other hand there's a reason that it
has persisted over the very long period
of time that it has and that has to do
with the fact that it actually as costly
as it is and the belief system is costly
the opportunity cost is very high the
reason that it has persisted is that it
has clearly given advantages to those
subscribe to it and that is in conflict
with the connotations of cult that we
carry with us a cult is an exploitative
version of a belief system where
somebody offers you the promise of
something valuable to you but in fact
what they end up doing is typically
robbing you blind or in some way getting
you to enslave yourself to them or
something along those lines
so if you look at the Catholic Church
you have to take it as a whole
and there's been a lot of bad but it it
is coupled to something that has
obviously served Catholics well over a
long period of time the next one i'm
threaded by oh I mean I'm going to just
read it normally and then we can talk
about it hether read this comment
imitating Brett's voice also Brett read
this comment
imitating Heather's voice which amuses
me I will say it's interesting I've saw
that as you were talking I was thinking
about it and as you know I strangely I
have an ability that I didn't know I had
to actually imitate voices of people
compellingly and it has never occurred
to me to do you and I think I've never
tried and I don't know how it's like
it's like you're too close yeah well no
I there's no text here really I mean I
think I think it would be easier if we
had a sentence written by the other to
imitate it where are we it's I'm on the
right it's it's this one but it's just
the comment is just read this comment
imitating oh yeah it's funny you know I
think this actually lines up if you try
to conjure the face of somebody that you
know well in the absence of a picture of
them or them sitting in front of you
it's often kind of hard to do um I think
this is a little bit like that where
it's just like you know there's not
you're not a picture of you you're you
know a hundred thousand different images
and different like we live in each other
as well you know it's it's so close
yeah that it's really hard to separate
maybe it may be hope maybe I'll work on
it but at the moment there's just so
little separation at all you know we
just have no distance from one another
that I think I think imitation how
required is some distance in order to
get perspective all right well you're
gonna see if you can figure out how to
to impersonate me and if you would do me
a favor and also figure out how to
impersonate me impersonating you
absolutely really take the pressure off
okay okay so we're really close to down
to so many good questions here guys I'm
gonna read two more out of this one and
I'm gonna go back I think and let's just
put one other from the other super chat
and and then we'll stop for today okay
so there next to an order here a
follow-up from echo Johnny Peterson
replied to you Brett and the Harris
debate quote that's why the process by
which the knowledge is updated has to
occupy a position in the hierarchy of
values that supersedes their reliance on
dogma how do you disagree yeah that's a
great quote from Peterson yeah it is a
great quote um I mean I must say I don't
think Peterson and I disagree that
intensely and in fact what he
acknowledged during I guess it was the
second night of debates in Vancouver I
regard it as an essentially completely
satisfying acknowledgment of the point I
was trying to make that allows me to see
his point as valid right behaving as if
has clear value and it has limits and he
sees both so I'm not sure our position
in the end is substantially different
what he's saying here I have trouble
interpreting I mean I I think if you
translate what I think he's saying into
our language the compendium of wisdom is
not I mean if you have you ever tried to
read a Bible it don't work right it's
self contradictory it's not a novel
right it requires something to interpret
to highlight this section to downplay
that section with reference to history
and what I would say is this creates the
possibility of the compendium of wisdom
functioning far better as a living
document with why's interpreters then it
can function as just simply an
instruction manual but even the process
whereby the folks who decide what to
emphasize can be wise and farsighted
that has limits to and then this is the
point that we've been making which has
now become a theme of the Q&A here which
is the the priestly sacred and the
shamanistic often live together in the
same tradition so in other words the
priests may be subscribing to an
orthodoxy and figuring out how to apply
it to a modern circumstance and the
monastery may be aware of some sort of
tear in the fabric that needs dealing
with them the longer term but are not
directly interfacing with the public in
the same way and that process extends
the flexibility potentially of the
apparatus that doles out the wisdom but
ultimately you will get to a point where
novelty will be so great that the
apparatus that evolved in light of past
variation will be inadequate to address
the present circumstance and our point
is painful as it is we pretty clearly
have arrived there in the 21st century
okay one more question from this live
chat then we'll pick up two from the
previous one and then we'll sign off
this next one is from the militant
moderate in response to our earlier
question his earlier question I assume
his
he says what a thought you folks who
becomes conversant in the Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy Douglas Adams claims
that the smartest organisms on Earth
were hyper-intelligent pan-dimensional
beings manifesting here as mice yes we
missed it missed the reference the first
time got it all right
last two questions in black swan versus
normal distribution discussion couldn't
we point to outliers in the evolutionary
process is it reasonable to say that all
traits cultural or biological first
appears outliers almost I guess almost a
tautology right it absolutely has to be
which is why I went here because this
seemed like something we could do pretty
pretty quickly yeah absolutely and then
finally social distancing seems to try
excuse me social distancing seems to
treat coronavirus like fleas that will
jump if you get too close rather than a
complex touch transmission is it an
effective safety proxy are we wasting
resources on a bad strategy I think the
the viral particles are a bit like fleas
actually this seems it seems the the
evidence that I've seen and yes we
expect the virus to change strategies
over time but the evidence that I've
seen and that we've seen suggests that
direct transmission through you know
catapulting droplets out of your mouth
either through you know yelling or
exertion or singing or yes even talking
pretty quietly is actually the most
effective mode of transmission and
picking stuff up from surfaces that
you've touched it's certainly possible
but it's far less likely to transmit the
virus that way well I want to amend that
slightly I think what we're learning
about the number of particles necessary
before transmission becomes likely so is
viral load in the air question suggested
it's not exactly fleet like I think
about a yep flea infestation is that if
it's the wrong flea you know pregnant
flea leaves on dia now you're in Festiva
fleas in this case the flea is more
analogous to a sufficiently dense cloud
of these particles
and so what I think what my model you
and I are walking down the street in
Portland the other day um yes we had to
be out there they're walking down the
street we were walking by some homeless
people they were eating on a wall
somewhere and one of them coughed and
the point was okay this person may be
sick with kovat 19
I almost people have many fewer
resources to protect themselves that
cough may have contained droplets a
brief encounter with that cloud is
unlikely to transmit the disease
possible absolutely
likely no standing where that cloud was
greatly increases to likelihood and so
you just saw that guy's friends are more
likely to become infected by hanging out
with him than we are by walking by him
right and so I think we all need to
update our model where every time you
enter a circumstance where you may have
just walked into a cloud of the stuff
that you cannot see you walk into a
space into an elevator and you don't
know if somebody just got out of that
elevator who had it and coughed right
hey hey stop watch starts the longer you
stay there the more you breathe while
you're there the more you will cross the
threshold in which exposure that does
not cause an infection crosses over into
an infection and so if you take that
model and you allow it to modify your
behavior you can actually greatly reduce
the chances of catching this thing and
that is what we should be doing and boy
I wish we were all on the same page
about this I really this is a moment at
which the world could be galvanized
where we would all be learning in tandem
about the danger we face how it is best
managed and we could manage this thing
into oblivion but not if we're tearing
each other apart all right have we
arrived there yeah all right well
excellent questions thank you so much
for them please if you have not already
liked the video subscribe share it with
your friends make a comment
and we will see you in the next
livestream which is scheduled for tea is
Tuesday all right
be well everyone